The following episode of How We Made Your Mother was recorded live on Instagram on January 28th, 2026.
《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的下一集于 2026 年 1 月 28 日在 Instagram 上现场录制。
Hello, good people of Instagram.
大家好，Instagram 的好人们。
Welcome.
欢迎。
Craig Thomas.
克雷格·托马斯.
I'm here with Craig Thomas.
我和克雷格·托马斯在一起。
Craig Thomas, my dear friend, co-created the show, How I Met Your Mother with his friend and my friend Carter Bayes.
我亲爱的朋友克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 与他的朋友、我的朋友卡特·贝叶斯 (Carter Bayes) 共同创作了这部剧《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
And we've been doing a podcast called How We Made Your Mother, where we go back through the show, been watching it with my wife, Jordana, who's never seen the show.
我们一直在做一个名为《我们如何创造你的母亲》的播客，我们会回顾这个节目，和我从未看过这个节目的妻子乔丹娜一起观看。
I haven't seen it in many years either.
我也很多年没见过了。
I mean, Craig, it's been a couple years since you've seen it.
我的意思是，克雷格，你已经好几年没看过它了。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
So we're having a great time.
所以我们玩得很开心。
We just finished watching season two.
我们刚刚看完第二季。
So we're what, 44 episodes into the 208?
那么，208 集已经有 44 集了？
Crazy.
疯狂的。
We made a little dent.
我们取得了一些进展。
It's not a huge dent, but we're getting there.
这不是一个巨大的凹痕，但我们正在实现这一目标。
We're looking to find people who don't know the podcast exists yet.
我们正在寻找还不知道播客存在的人。
We're looking at we're going from more fans.
我们正在寻找更多粉丝。
Yeah.
是的。
If you are watching this podcast or listening rather, and you're enjoying it.
如果您正在观看或收听此播客，并且您很享受它。
Please recruit your family and your friends to join you in the joy of this.
请召集您的家人和朋友来加入您的喜悦。
And if you're just discovering us now, welcome.
如果您现在才发现我们，欢迎。
We're so happy to have you.
我们很高兴有你。
Start from episode one.
从第一集开始。
It's a great lesson.
这是一个很好的教训。
The episodes go by just like him and him itself.
这些情节就像他和他自己一样过去。
Go down easy.
轻松下去。
But we are going deep into what made the show so special, what makes it so beloved after all these years.
但我们正在深入探讨是什么让这部剧如此特别，是什么让它在这么多年之后如此受人喜爱。
And Craig, now we're 44 episodes in, like, what has struck you overall about, like, the show we made together, especially the first two seasons?
克雷格，现在我们已经有 44 集了，比如，我们一起制作的这部剧，尤其是前两季，总体上让你印象深刻的是什么？
Like, what are your big thoughts right now?
比如，你现在最大的想法是什么？
I really like it.
我真的很喜欢它。
Yeah, I really do.
是的，我真的这么做。
Yeah.
是的。
I find the best part of it is I feel not judgmental of it.
我发现它最好的部分是我不去评判它。
Like, I was so analytical and so lost in the weeds and the details and is the sound mix right.
就像，我是如此善于分析，迷失在杂草和细节中，声音混合是否正确。
And when we would watch it with my wife on Monday nights when it and I'd sit there and go, you didn't laugh.
当我们周一晚上和我的妻子一起观看它时，当它和我坐在那里离开时，你没有笑。
Did you not hear that word?
你没听到这个词吗？
Did we not mix?
我们没有混在一起吗？
Was the music too hot against the dialogue?
音乐是否太火爆，不利于对话？
And she'd be like, this is the worst.
她会说，这是最糟糕的。
Can I wash this without you from now on?
从现在起我可以在没有你的情况下洗这个吗？
And I was so like so intense about every little thing.
我对每一件小事都如此热情。
And then now it's so great to just let it wash over me.
现在让它冲刷我真是太棒了。
I watched it and I just enjoy it.
我看了它并且很享受。
It almost took 20 years to be able to watch it without that kind of neurotic thing.
差不多花了20年才能够没有那种神经质的东西看下去。
But you know what's funny?
但你知道有什么好笑的吗？
I did the same thing, but mostly around my own performance or whether that joke didn't work or like I should have done this, I can't tell you what any of those things were that I was worried about.
我也做了同样的事情，但主要是围绕我自己的表现，或者那个笑话是否行得通，或者我应该这样做，我无法告诉你我担心的是什么。
Right, I'm not a thing at all.
没错，我根本就不是一个东西。
What was I so, I don't know what was I so excited about?
我到底是怎么了，我不知道我到底在兴奋什么？
Yeah, I was so proud of myself.
是的，我为自己感到骄傲。
Yeah, this is a great lesson.
是的，这是一个很好的教训。
Please take this lesson from us, good people of Instagram and this podcast.
请从我们这些 Instagram 和这个播客的好人身上吸取教训。
Be generous to yourself.
对自己慷慨一点。
If you're basically doing a good job, be like, I'm doing okay here.
如果你基本上做得很好，那就说，我在这里做得很好。
Although maybe the lesson is you gotta get some years under your belt before you can learn to do that.
尽管也许教训是你必须经过几年的训练才能学会这样做。
Yes, you know, I do think that age confers, if you age with some grace, it confers a more forgiveness both for yourself and for other people, you know, that you realize, by the time you're our age, 50, 51, you realize you're just a bundle of flaws, you know, you're just like, you're never gonna, Oh yes.
是的，你知道，我确实认为年龄赋予，如果你以某种优雅的方式变老，它会给你自己和他人更多的宽恕，你知道，你意识到，当你到了我们这个年纪，50、51，你意识到你只是一堆缺陷，你知道，你就像，你永远不会，哦，是的。
The perfection that you chased in your 20s is not attainable and you have some acceptance of that.
你在20多岁时所追求的完美是无法实现的，但你已经接受了这一点。
So we're really happy to be able to revisit the show and almost like talk to our younger selves, much like, you know, the older narrator character.
所以我们真的很高兴能够重温这部剧，几乎就像和年轻的自己交谈，就像，你知道的，年长的叙述者角色。
We are featured head, that's the way.
我们是特色头，就是这样。
It's nice to be able to talk to your past self and say, kid, you did okay.
很高兴能够与过去的自己交谈并说，孩子，你做得很好。
You know, you did a really good job.
你知道，你做得非常好。
So we're really happy you're here.
所以我们真的很高兴你来到这里。
Thanks for joining us tonight.
感谢您今晚加入我们。
You can see the blue French horn, behind me that's the actual blue French horn.
你可以看到蓝色圆号，在我身后那是真正的蓝色圆号。
Please do not break into my home steal that.
请不要闯入我家偷那个。
No, this isn't even my half.
不，这甚至不是我的一半。
No, I'm kidding.
不，我在开玩笑。
But yeah, we're really happy you're here.
但是，是的，我们真的很高兴你来到这里。
We're gonna try to answer a bunch of your bunch of your questions.
我们将尽力回答您的一系列问题。
Alec though, our producer, Alec Lev, a long time associated with how I met my mother for years.
不过，我们的制片人亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）多年来一直与我如何认识我的母亲联系在一起。
He was the digital content creator and he ran he hosted the podcast that we did for a long time.
他是数字内容创作者，他主持了我们很长一段时间的播客。
And Alec is now our producer.
亚历克现在是我们的制片人。
So we're always happy to see him and he will referee.
所以我们总是很高兴见到他并且他会担任裁判。
He will keep this thing civilized.
他会让这件事保持文明。
What do you got for us, Alec?
你给我们准备了什么，亚历克？
The most important thing I have in high now, everyone, is Josh, can you make sure to plug in your iPhone?
我现在在high最重要的事情，大家，是Josh，你能确保你的iPhone插上电源吗？
I'm getting a message that your iPhone is running out of power.
我收到一条消息，提示您的 iPhone 电量即将耗尽。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
So you just do that where we talk.
所以你只要在我们谈话的地方这样做就可以了。
Where is it at?
它在哪里？
Instagram.
Instagram。
Let's see how I do that.
让我们看看我是如何做到的。
Yeah, Josh is going to work on that.
是的，乔什会努力解决这个问题。
He's got about 20% battery left.
他还剩下大约 20% 的电量。
All right, all right, hold on.
好吧好吧，坚持住。
We might be able to get through, it's 20%, though, right?
我们也许能够通过，不过是20%，对吧？
I could say a couple of things here.
我可以在这里说几件事。
First of all, is Alex Lourdes, high out there, she asks, is this live or pre-recorded?
首先，亚历克斯·卢尔德 (Alex Lourdes) 问道，这是现场直播还是预先录制的？
I think this is for Alex.
我想这是给亚历克斯的。
I think we're answering this really well right now.
我认为我们现在已经很好地回答了这个问题。
Is this live?
这是直播吗？
And Josh isn't there right now?
乔什现在不在吗？
I think you know it's live.
我想你知道它是直播的。
That's not a creative choice for me.
这对我来说不是一个创造性的选择。
I'm just going to also shout out some country.
我也想大声喊出某个国家。
Everyone here who is putting in their country's flags, it looks great.
这里的每个人都插上了自己国家的国旗，看起来很棒。
but I don't know what the flags represent for all of them.
但我不知道这些旗帜对他们来说代表什么。
So if you could type out your country, we'd love to read out where everyone is coming from.
因此，如果您可以输入您的国家/地区，我们很乐意读出每个人来自哪里。
I'm just gonna read a few here.
我只想在这里读一些。
We've got El Salvador and Iran, China, Canada, Brazil, Peru, Mexico, Portugal, Turkey, Argentina, and Spain.
我们有萨尔瓦多、伊朗、中国、加拿大、巴西、秘鲁、墨西哥、葡萄牙、土耳其、阿根廷和西班牙。
Absolutely incredible.
绝对令人难以置信。
Hey, everybody.
嘿，大家。
Thank you for joining us.
感谢您加入我们。
Thank you for watching how much your mother all around the world.
感谢您关注世界各地的母亲。
This is such an international show, this show.
这是一场如此国际化的演出。
It's gone so international.
已经变得如此国际化了。
We hear from people all over the place.
我们收到了各地人们的来信。
It's such an honor and we're hearing that on the pod a lot.
这是一种荣幸，我们在 Pod 上经常听到这样的说法。
A lot of people that write in or send its voice messages, they're from really unexpected to cool places and it blows our minds every time.
很多人写下或发送语音消息，他们来自真正意想不到的很酷的地方，每次都让我们大吃一惊。
It's so cool.
太酷了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
Mr. Maseko 11 says, there's a podcast with a lot of question marks.
Maseko 11 先生说，有一个播客有很多问号。
See, this is the problem.
你看，这就是问题所在。
You spread the word.
你传播了这个消息。
We gotta spread the word, man.
我们必须传播这个消息，伙计。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Flooky.shh says the same thing I didn't know it existed.
Flooky.shh 说了同样的话，我不知道它存在。
So we're doing this.
所以我们正在这样做。
This is why we're doing this, is one of the reasons why we're doing this, but please, if you are, you're listening to this either right now, you're live with us right now, or it might be that you're listening to this as a podcast, because this is going to be in our podcast feed, in a couple of weeks.
这就是我们这样做的原因，也是我们这样做的原因之一，但是请注意，如果您是的话，您现在正在听这个，您现在和我们一起生活，或者您可能正在以播客的形式收听这个，因为这将在几周后出现在我们的播客提要中。
Yeah, so if you're, by the way, we're having a really good comedy that happened where when Josh is making noise, it cuts to his shot, but it's just his empty frame of a fireplace and the blueprint's short and he's nowhere to be seen, and it's making me laugh every time, I'm sorry.
是的，顺便说一句，如果你正在观看一部非常精彩的喜剧，当乔什发出噪音时，镜头就会切入，但那只是他的空壁炉架，而且蓝图很短，他也无处可见，这每次都让我发笑，我很抱歉。
This isn't gonna be great audio content.
这不会是很棒的音频内容。
Here he is, we got him.
他在这里，我们抓住了他。
That's all right.
没关系。
Here he is.
他在这里。
Is that charging?
那是充电吗？
Yes.
是的。
As long as it's charging, it's good.
只要能充电就很好。
Lish defense.
利什防守。
Eagle had fans spying on your phone charge.
老鹰有粉丝监视你的手机电量。
Wait, was that you or Alec?
等等，是你还是亚历克？
That was a fan, a fan wrote it in, right?
那是一个粉丝，一个粉丝写的，对吧？
Alec?
亚历克？
No?
不？
No, no, no, it was, no, it was Riverside.
不，不，不，那是，不，那是河畔。
Riverside on New Jersey.
新泽西州河滨。
It was Riverside, okay, I thought a fan could see it.
那是河滨，好吧，我以为球迷可以看到它。
I can see it.
我能看到它。
Yeah.
是的。
Lish, Lish dish 13 says this podcast to change my relationship with the show in the best way possible.
Lish，Lish 菜肴 13 说这个播客以尽可能最好的方式改变我与节目的关系。
And then, um, hmm, Laysmark solely says, is there a podcast where you can comment on the show?
然后，嗯，嗯，Laysmark 只是说，有一个播客可以让你对节目发表评论吗？
Well, um, Josh, why don't you explain to people how they can comment on the, on the podcast, where they can write into us?
嗯，乔什，你为什么不向人们解释一下他们如何在播客上发表评论，在哪里可以给我们写信呢？
Yeah, so if you listen to the show, uh, one of the first, uh, the things you'll hear, uh, is we often will play a voice note or a voice memo from, uh, a fan from all over the world.
是的，所以如果你听这个节目，呃，第一个，呃，你会听到的，呃，是我们经常会播放来自世界各地的粉丝的语音笔记或语音备忘录。
we've heard from people all over the world.
我们收到了世界各地人们的来信。
And the prompt is essentially, what is how I met your mother mean to you?
提示本质上是，我如何认识你母亲对你来说意味着什么？
Just tell us what the show means to you.
请告诉我们这个节目对您意味着什么。
And we've gotten the most extraordinary, beautiful, heartfelt, amazing letters.
我们收到了最非凡、最美丽、最真诚、最令人惊叹的信件。
So that's a voice memo.
这就是语音备忘录。
If you want us to potentially play your voice memo on air, I'll tell you how in one second, but you can also write us a letter, good old fashioned email.
如果您希望我们在广播中播放您的语音备忘录，我会立即告诉您如何操作，但您也可以给我们写一封信，很好的老式电子邮件。
So go to how we made your mother.com or HWMYM.com, go to contact and just follow the instructions.
因此，请转到我们如何创建您的 mother.com 或 HWMYM.com，前往联系方式并按照说明进行操作。
It should be pretty self-explanatory.
这应该是不言自明的。
But we'd love to hear from you.
但我们很乐意听取您的意见。
So, yeah, send us that.
所以，是的，请将其发送给我们。
It's by far the best, our favorite part.
这是迄今为止最好的、我们最喜欢的部分。
It's the best part of doing this.
这是这样做最好的部分。
It's hearing from the fans, and it's always a big part of every episode of the podcast.
它来自粉丝的声音，并且始终是播客每一集的重要组成部分。
So get involved, come listen, and yeah, join us there.
所以参与进来，来听听，是的，加入我们吧。
What else have we got, Alec?
我们还有什么，亚历克？
How do we answer questions now?
现在我们如何回答问题？
Well, we could do that.
嗯，我们可以这么做。
First of all, by the way, let's just have a conversation with our friend here, Alex Lourdes, who was wondering if this was live, who says the intro was so smooth, I thought it was pre-recorded.
首先，顺便说一句，让我们和我们的朋友 Alex Lourdes 聊聊，他想知道这是否是现场直播，他说介绍非常顺利，我以为这是预先录制的。
So, right, probably right up until the...
所以，对，可能直到……
It was really, it fooled me until you guys shot the bed with the battery tray.
真的，它愚弄了我，直到你们用电池托盘射击了床。
When it would be amazing if it was pre-recorded, but we were such geniuses that we built in the iPhone debacle.
如果它是预先录制的，那就太棒了，但我们是如此天才，以至于我们在 iPhone 的崩溃中构建了它。
Yeah.
是的。
On the block.
在街区上。
Okay, so here's just a lovely question here from I Am Nina Now says from Buenos Aires, although not exactly the question, I want to thank Josh for writing kind over matter on a piece of paper a few years ago so I could get it tattooed.
好吧，这只是我现在是尼娜在布宜诺斯艾利斯说的一个可爱的问题，虽然不完全是这个问题，但我要感谢乔什几年前在一张纸上写下了善意的内容，这样我就可以把它纹身了。
Wow, was that in, I wonder if it was in Buenos Aires when Ben Lee and I played there in like maybe 2017?
哇，那是在吗？我想知道 2017 年 Ben Lee 和我在那儿打球时是否是在布宜诺斯艾利斯？
Let us know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
让我们知道，是啊，是啊，是啊。
That's awesome, we'd love to see the tattoo.
太棒了，我们很想看看纹身。
Yeah, a lot of tattoos, right Craig?
是的，有很多纹身，对吧克雷格？
We've seen so many of how I met your mother-related tattoos.
我们见过很多与你母亲有关的纹身。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
That wasn't exactly that instance.
那不完全是那个例子。
That was something Josh did that was awesome.
乔什所做的事情非常棒。
But him and fans are sending us some pretty.
但他和粉丝们给我们带来了一些漂亮的东西。
A lot of yellow umbrella.
很多黄色的雨伞。
Lou French horn speaking of quotes from the show.
卢用圆号讲述节目中的台词。
All kinds of stuff.
各种各样的东西。
What an honor for things from the show to be on somebody's body.
剧中的东西能出现在某人身上是多么荣幸啊。
That's a fan.
那是一个粉丝。
That's a real fan.
这才是真正的粉丝。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，寄给你在纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客，或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
Okay, I'm gonna just start off with just a really big question here, because it's a lovely one.
好吧，我将从一个非常大的问题开始，因为这是一个可爱的问题。
It might take some time for you guys to think about, or you might have several answers to, so let's just go for it.
你们可能需要一些时间去思考，或者你们可能有几个答案，所以让我们继续吧。
This actually comes to us from Instagram.
这实际上来自 Instagram。
Benny Belive says, it would be so interesting to know what was your favorite day on set and why.
Benny Belive 说，如果知道你在片场最喜欢哪一天以及为什么，那会很有趣。
Is there a special day where everyone just had the best work day?
有没有一个特别的日子让每个人都度过了最好的工作日？
Or would you say that every day of shooting was special in its own way?
或者你会说拍摄的每一天都有其独特的方式吗？
Thank you so much for entertainment over all these years.
非常感谢您这些年来的娱乐。
The series makes me smile.
这个系列让我微笑。
I can't, it's so cool that you're doing this here in 2026.
我不能，你在 2026 年在这里做这件事真是太酷了。
So, if you're just thinking back, especially to these first two seasons, are there days that to just pop into your mind as being memorable for one reason or another.
所以，如果你回想一下，尤其是前两季，是否有一些日子会因为这样或那样的原因而突然出现在你的脑海中令人难忘。
Yeah, that's a great question.
是的，这是一个很好的问题。
I think that I want to answer the second part of what he asked though about was every day the best.
我想我想回答他问的第二部分，虽然每天都是最好的。
And I will say no to that.
我对此会说不。
And that's just, that's just because we did nine years.
那只是，那只是因为我们做了九年。
And if you take a decade of your life, no matter where you are, how your work it would, like you're gonna have good days and you're gonna have not so good days, but you gotta show up at the office anyway, you know?
如果你生命中的十年，无论你在哪里，你的工作会如何，就像你会度过美好的日子，也会度过不太美好的日子，但无论如何你都必须出现在办公室，你知道吗？
So you just have to bring yourself wherever you are.
所以无论你身在何处，你只需要带上自己。
I think when the cameras rolled, we all tried to drink the fake beer and eat the Chex mix and do our jobs and sell the jokes and authentically play our parts.
我想当镜头转动时，我们都试图喝假啤酒，吃 Chex 混合饮料，做我们的工作，卖笑话，真实地扮演我们的角色。
But some days were hard on set and other days, I will say it wasn't all like the blooper reel, although every moment from the Bulletproof reel actually happened and was as funny and joyful as it looked, you know?
但有些日子在片场很艰难，而另一些日子，我会说这并不完全像《防弹卷轴》那样，尽管《防弹卷轴》中的每一个时刻都真实发生过，而且就像看起来一样有趣和快乐，你知道吗？
So I think that when I think of like happy moments on set, for some reason, this always stays with me.
所以我认为，当我想起片场的快乐时刻时，出于某种原因，这总是伴随着我。
And I think I talked about this once on the podcast.
我想我曾经在播客上谈到过这个问题。
We would often do like early morning or breakfast scenes, you know, Marshall, Lilly, and Ted in sweatpants having breakfast, you know?
我们经常喜欢清晨或早餐的场景，你知道，马歇尔、莉莉和泰德穿着运动裤吃早餐，你知道吗？
We just, what happened?
我们只是，发生了什么？
Josh, can you just say that last thing one more time?
乔什，你能再说一遍最后一句话吗？
we just lost your last two sentences there.
我们刚刚丢失了你的最后两句话。
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
Well, when I think about happy moments on set, is that what you were talking about?
好吧，当我想到片场的快乐时光时，这就是你所说的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
When I think about happy moments on set, we often, I think I talked about this on the podcast at one point, but Jason and Ali and myself, as Ted Marshall and Lily, we would often do like breakfast scenes.
当我想到片场的快乐时刻时，我们经常，我想我曾在播客上谈到过这一点，但杰森和阿里以及我自己，如特德·马歇尔和莉莉，我们经常会做早餐场景。
And for some reason, they would sometimes, Mike Shea, the way he structured them, the breakfast or early morning scenes would often be the first scenes of the day.
出于某种原因，迈克·谢伊（Mike Shea）有时会以他构建它们的方式，早餐或清晨的场景通常会是一天中的第一个场景。
So you drive to the Fox lot in Los Angeles, you'd get out of your car, you'd go through hair and makeup, and you'd go into your dressing room and you had to change into like a t-shirt and sweatpants.
所以你开车去洛杉矶的福克斯电视台，下车，做头发和化妆，然后走进更衣室，换上T恤和运动裤。
And then you get on set and Dave Baker, the props guy goes, what cereal do you want?
然后你到了片场，道具师戴夫·贝克（Dave Baker）问，你想要什么麦片？
What do you want in your coffee?
您想在咖啡中加入什么？
And then you would just sit there and have breakfast and drink coffee and make each other laugh.
然后你们就坐在那里吃早餐，喝咖啡，互相逗笑。
And it was just like, there were those moments where you're like, I can't believe I'm getting paid for that.
就像，有些时候你会想，我不敢相信我会为此得到报酬。
Like, I have someone's gonna come and discover that this is like too fun, like too much fun.
就像，我有人会来发现这太有趣了，太有趣了。
It's too, it was just a blast, you know, to have that be your job, you know?
这也太棒了，你知道，这就是你的工作，你知道吗？
And yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Yeah, I would just add on to that too and say that there would just be certain moments every so often, because you lose, it's what Josh is saying, it's your job.
是的，我也想补充一点，那就是每隔一段时间就会有某些时刻，因为你输了，这就是乔什所说的，这是你的工作。
It's every day you start taking it for granted.
每一天你都开始认为这是理所当然的。
It doesn't feel like showbiz every day or magical, magical every second.
感觉不像演艺圈的每一天，也不像神奇的每一秒。
But every now and again, there'd be some moment where I'd just take a half step back and I'd look at Josh Radner reading dialogue that I wrote or that Carter wrote or that we all fashioned together on the writers from the day before.
但时不时地，会有一些时刻，我会退后半步，看着乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）阅读我写的、卡特写的、或者我们一起根据前一天的作家们共同创作的对话。
Josh and Kobe acting in a scene together and then they kind of zoom out and you go, and there's Pam Fryman directing it and there's our entire crew and there's Dave Baker with the Lucky Charms for whoever ordered Lucky Charms and whatever it was.
乔什和科比一起表演一个场景，然后他们拉远了，你就走了，帕姆·弗莱曼执导，我们整个工作人员都有，戴夫·贝克带着幸运符，无论谁订购了幸运符什么的。
And like every now and again, I'd sort of like grasp the totality of it and just go like, this is everyone's here on the same mission, right?
就像时不时地一样，我有点想掌握它的整体，然后就想，这是每个人都在执行同一个使命，对吗？
We all, we came up with this thing and we said, hey everybody, would you come into our little universe and yes and it and kind of play with us?
我们大家想出了这个东西，我们说，嘿大家，你们愿意进入我们的小宇宙吗？是的，它和我们一起玩吗？
Like two kids playing together.
就像两个孩子在一起玩耍一样。
I think that's the spirit of like, we're gonna play, we're gonna get our Star Wars guys, we're gonna play.
我认为这就是我们要比赛的精神，我们要让我们的星球大战人员，我们要比赛。
And every now and again, it would occur to me, like you just said, Josh, like, how is this our job?
时不时地，我会想到，就像你刚才说的，乔希，这怎么是我们的工作？
How are we able to come do this?
我们怎样才能做到这一点？
How is everybody here agreeing this universe exists and making it up together?
这里的每个人如何同意这个宇宙存在并共同组成？
And every now and again, that feeling would hit me and it was the greatest feeling.
这种感觉时不时地袭来，这是最棒的感觉。
I felt that when I directed both movies I wrote, I was like, I dreamt this scene up in a coffee shop.
我觉得当我导演我写的两部电影时，我就像是，我在一家咖啡店里梦见了这个场景。
Yeah.
是的。
This started in my imagination and now all these people are bringing it to life.
这开始于我的想象，现在所有这些人都将它变为现实。
And I can't believe I'm looking through a camera and seeing kind of what I dreamt up, but better.
我不敢相信我通过相机看到了我梦想的东西，而且更好。
Better.
更好的。
Yeah, that's it.
是的，就是这样。
That's it, it's the humbling feeling of how much better it is than you could have ever dreamt it to be.
就是这样，这是一种谦卑的感觉，它比你想象的要好得多。
It feels, that's the magic, that's the magical piece.
感觉，这就是魔法，这就是神奇的作品。
I will say also, there's something called, I think it's called the hedonic treadmill.
我还要说，有一种东西叫做，我想它叫做享乐跑步机。
Have you ever heard of that phrase?
你听说过这句话吗？
It's basically like the things you dream about and it's basically how quickly we metabolize our good fortune that the thing you wanted five years ago, you have it and you're suddenly like, the couches here are terrible.
这基本上就像你梦想的东西，基本上就是我们代谢我们的好运气的速度有多快，你五年前想要的东西，你已经拥有了，你突然觉得，这里的沙发很糟糕。
Like you just immediately go back to your same level of dissatisfaction and looking forward to the next thing.
就像你立即回到同样的不满程度并期待下一件事。
And you know, I knew that this was a great gig and I knew that the writing was really sharp and I knew the cast was jelling and I knew we were firing all cylinders.
你知道，我知道这是一场很棒的演出，我知道剧本非常犀利，我知道演员阵容正在凝聚，我知道我们正在全力以赴。
And still, you have days where you're like, like you're dragging your feet, you're not as inspired.
然而，有时候你会觉得自己拖拖拉拉，没有那么有灵感。
One thing that would happen is, when people would come and visit, like if out of town, like some of my parents would drop by set or family friends or whatever who wanted to come by.
会发生的一件事是，当人们来拜访时，就像出城一样，就像我的一些父母会顺便拜访剧组或家人朋友或任何想过来的人。
There was something about having the external, like when someone from Ohio comes to visit.
有一些关于外部的东西，比如当有人从俄亥俄州来拜访时。
Yes, and you see it through their eyes.
是的，你通过他们的眼睛看到了这一点。
You see it through their eyes.
你通过他们的眼睛看到了这一点。
Those days were actually really interesting to me because I was like, oh, this is a cool job.
那些日子对我来说真的很有趣，因为我想，哦，这是一份很酷的工作。
Like this is really interesting fun.
这样的事情真是有趣好玩。
Yeah.
是的。
But you just, it's not that you take it for granted.
但你只是，并不是你认为这是理所当然的。
It just, the repetition, it just becomes something.
它只是，重复，它就变成了某种东西。
just becomes your life.
就成为你的生活。
It's your daily life, it's your normal.
这是你的日常生活，这是你的常态。
And then every now and again, you're reminded, this is not normal in the best way possible.
然后时不时地，你会被提醒，这在最好的情况下是不正常的。
This is not normal.
这是不正常的。
This is really extraordinary what's happening here.
这里发生的事情确实非同寻常。
And it's just human nature.
这只是人性。
You do, you get used to stuff, you don't always appreciate the magic.
你确实如此，你已经习惯了这些东西，你并不总是欣赏它的魔力。
I'm coming, I'm like, parenthood is clicking into my brain here a little bit, right?
我来了，我想，为人父母的感觉有点进入我的大脑，对吧？
You have these amazing little humans and you sort of, in between those moments of like, wonder and appreciation, you're doing the grunt work of parenting and you're sometimes losing the magic of like what that is and then like something hits you and you're like, fuck, wait, this is the greatest thing in the world.
你有这些令人惊叹的小人类，在那些喜欢、惊奇和欣赏的时刻之间，你正在做着养育孩子的繁重工作，有时你会失去那种神奇的感觉，然后就像有什么东西击中了你，你会想，他妈的，等等，这是世界上最伟大的事情。
And it's akin to that.
与此类似。
And it's almost like the grunt work is part of the magic because without that, it's like it doesn't, you know, if you just went.
这几乎就像繁重的工作是魔法的一部分，因为如果没有它，就好像它不是一样，你知道，如果你刚刚去了。
You're earning the magic with the grunt work.
你通过艰苦的工作赢得了魔法。
If you just went from triumph to triumph, let's say you were just like an actor that was just triumphant and you just won every award, Like, there would be something you would hate about that, eventually.
如果你只是从一个胜利走向另一个胜利，假设你就像一个刚刚胜利的演员，你刚刚赢得了每一个奖项，就像，最终会有一些你会讨厌的东西。
Yeah, oh yeah.
是啊，哦，是啊。
You'd be like, there's no, where's the struggle, where's the ascent, where's the resilience that I'm having to find, you know?
你会说，没有，哪里有挣扎，哪里有上升，哪里有我必须找到的韧性，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's a hard thing because it's hard to struggle, but without struggle, who are we?
这是一件很难的事情，因为很难奋斗，但如果没有奋斗，我们是谁？
We don't get forged, you know?
我们不会被伪造，你知道吗？
Yeah, I think that's right.
是的，我认为这是对的。
And I think we also made it hard on ourselves in a good way on how Mitch and Mother, because he didn't do the same episode every week.
我认为我们在米奇和母亲的表现上也让自己很为难，因为他每周都没有演同一集。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It wasn't the cookie cutter.
这不是饼干刀。
Like here is basically what a himium episode is.
就像这里基本上就是一个 hiium 剧集。
We're going to do this 200 times more or less.
我们将或多或少地执行此操作 200 次。
We've really tried it.
我们确实尝试过。
We're always challenging yourself and almost like challenging every department.
我们总是在挑战自己，几乎就像在挑战每个部门。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
The whole thing was challenged accepted and everyone accepted it and that's the magic.
整件事都被接受了，每个人都接受了挑战，这就是魔力。
We just talked about something borrowed, something blue, which is the one where Marshall shaved the landing strip in his head at the before the wedding, something borrowed.
我们刚刚谈论了一些借来的东西，一些蓝色的东西，这是马歇尔在婚礼前剃掉了头上的着陆跑道，借来的东西。
So it's some, it's the finale, right?
所以这是一些，这是结局，对吧？
This season finale season.
本季最后一季。
I thought it was something borrowed, though.
不过我以为那是借来的东西。
Oh, something borrowed, right, yeah, isn't it?
哦，借来的东西，对吧，是的，不是吗？
Sorry, you're absolutely right.
抱歉，你说得完全正确。
Yeah, so something borrowed was...
是啊，借来的东西是……
Second of all.
其次。
Jason gets the cool guy tips, he freaks out, and he takes the razor and he shaves that reverse mohawk in his head.
杰森得到了酷哥的建议，他吓坏了，他拿起剃刀，剃掉了头上的莫霍克发型。
Yeah.
是的。
And I said to Craig, I was like, if you're in the hair department reading the script, you're like, oh shit.
我对克雷格说，我当时想，如果你在发型部门读剧本，你会说，哦，该死。
Like, we have to get frosted tips on Jason's hair somehow, and then we have to create an effect where he takes a razor.
就像，我们必须以某种方式在杰森的头发上磨砂，然后我们必须创造一个他拿着剃刀的效果。
Jase is ahead.
杰斯领先。
Yeah.
是的。
Like, I mean, it was a huge ask of the makeup, I mean, that shot department.
就像，我的意思是，这对化妆、拍摄部门来说是一个巨大的要求。
There should have been a special Emmy just for that shot, how well that went.
应该为那个镜头颁发一个特别的艾美奖，那真是太棒了。
On the first try.
第一次尝试。
We only did one take of it.
我们只拍了一张。
And you can see me laughing for reals.
你可以看到我真的在笑。
Because it was a miracle.
因为这是一个奇迹。
We all be knew we had witnessed a miracle.
我们都知道我们见证了一个奇迹。
Yeah.
是的。
What else?
还有什么？
Paulo, I'd say, just as, hi Josh, hope you remember your concert in Sao Paulo, Brazil.
保罗，我想说，就像，嗨乔希，希望你记得你在巴西圣保罗举行的音乐会。
I gave you a flag with your names.
我给了你一面写有你名字的旗帜。
That's from Paulo.
那是保罗发来的。
I sure do remember that because 1200 people came and saw us in Sao Paulo and it was such a fun night.
我确实记得这一点，因为有 1200 人来看望我们在圣保罗，那真是一个有趣的夜晚。
So shout out to all the Brazilians.
所以向所有巴西人大声喊叫。
We had such a, Ben and I went there.
我们有这样一个，本和我去了那里。
We had five shows in Brazil, and yeah, I'd love to come back.
我们在巴西举办了五场演出，是的，我很想回来。
I very much remember that night.
我非常记得那个晚上。
Now we're back, our old friend, Work Work Eliza, is back saying that she's the one named after your grandmother Rose, but again, with no details.
现在我们回来了，我们的老朋友，工作工作伊丽莎回来了，说她是以你祖母罗斯的名字命名的，但同样没有透露任何细节。
So Work Work Eliza, while you're here, just are you saying that you are, have the same name as both of Josh's grandmothers?
所以工作工作伊丽莎，当你在这里的时候，你是说你和乔什的两个祖母同名吗？
And the grandmother was not named Eliza.
祖母不叫伊丽莎。
I just...
我只是...
Right, right.
对，对。
Well, the screen name is Work Work Eliza, but we understand that it's Rose, but Work Work Eliza Rose, if you could just expand a little, we are curious, if you were actually named after the person, or you just happen to have the same name, okay.
嗯，网名是 Work Work Eliza，但我们知道是 Rose，但是 Work Work Eliza Rose，如果你能扩展一点，我们很好奇，如果你真的是以这个人的名字命名的，或者只是碰巧有相同的名字，好吧。
Let's go with this one, people, you know what?
让我们开始吧，朋友们，你知道吗？
My friends, people love the deleted scenes, and Isaac Cardoza has a question, so many people ask, what are your favorite deleted scenes?
我的朋友们，人们喜欢删除的场景，艾萨克·卡多萨有一个问题，所以很多人问，你最喜欢删除的场景是什么？
What are some of your favorite bloopers that you remember, either from the moment or from actually going back to it.
你记得的最喜欢的花絮有哪些，无论是从那一刻开始还是在实际回顾时。
I'm curious, Josh, I don't totally, do you remember specific moments where you really lost your shit or you did something insane happen?
我很好奇，乔什，我完全不记得，你还记得你真的失去了你的狗屎或者你做了一些疯狂的事情的特定时刻吗？
What is that for you?
那对你来说是什么？
I remember Martin Short making me laugh quite a bit.
我记得马丁·肖特让我笑得很开心。
He's so funny.
他真有趣。
Well, bloopers are different than deleted scenes.
嗯，花絮与删除的场景不同。
Right, is it a blooper question?
对了，这是一个愚蠢的问题吗？
Something like that.
类似的事情。
That's true, I'm sorry.
确实如此，对不起。
This one does say deleted scenes.
这个确实说删除了场景。
Interesting, yeah.
有趣，是的。
I mean, there's a scene that I think is on the DVDs, but it was cut from the finale, me and Kobe, that scene in the diner, which I thought was quite important, actually.
我的意思是，有一个场景我认为在 DVD 上，但它是从结局中剪下来的，我和科比，餐厅里的那个场景，我认为实际上非常重要。
Yeah, I missed that scene, and I missed that scene.
是的，我错过了那个场景，我错过了那个场景。
That was the finale game in two hours.
这是两个小时后的最后一场比赛。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
That was the heart-breaker for me.
这让我心碎。
Yeah, but you can track that scene down.
是的，但是你可以追踪那个场景。
It might be on YouTube.
它可能在 YouTube 上。
It is, yeah, it's very easy to get.
是的，它很容易获得。
It's on YouTube, for sure, and it was on those DVDs, And yeah, look it up.
当然，它在 YouTube 上，也在那些 DVD 上，是的，查一下。
That was a really interesting scene in the finale that we just.
我们刚刚在结局中看到了一个非常有趣的场景。
And ends with the salute.
并以敬礼结束。
For whatever reason.
无论出于何种原因。
I didn't get in.
我没进去。
Yeah, I know.
是的，我知道。
That was a good scene.
那是一个很好的场景。
That should have been in there maybe.
也许应该在那里。
Yeah.
是的。
To make the argument.
来论证。
Oh well.
那好吧。
Lishdish13, by the way, wants to add, Josh, I was your merch girl in Sacramento at your show.
顺便说一句，Lishdish13 想要补充一点，乔什，我是你在萨克拉门托演出时的推销员。
Oh.
哦。
Your music is still my current obsession.
你的音乐仍然是我目前的痴迷。
Oh, that's so nice.
哦，那太好了。
Thank you for doing that.
谢谢你这么做。
Thanks to all the people that worked merch on my tour.
感谢所有为我的巡演提供商品的人。
Everyone was so kind and great.
每个人都那么友善和伟大。
And yeah.
是的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Alyssa speaks for many when she asks, what happened to Jordana's segment?
当艾莉莎问乔丹娜的片段怎么了时，她代表了很多人的心声。
We miss her.
我们想念她。
Yeah, well, she's upstairs.
是的，好吧，她在楼上。
All right, talk for no quiet, tell us what happened.
好吧，不安静地说话，告诉我们发生了什么事。
Yeah, I mean, we announced this on a couple of podcasts ago, but we had a baby.
是的，我的意思是，我们之前在几个播客上宣布了这一点，但我们有了一个孩子。
My wife and I had a baby boy.
我和我的妻子生了一个男婴。
So if you didn't know this, parenting is a lot of work, and so we just decided to pause her segment for a little bit.
所以，如果你不知道这一点，养育孩子是一项繁重的工作，所以我们决定暂停她的部分。
Well, I've been really gratified because we've heard so many people miss Jordana's segment, and she should be very flattered, and we should maybe be a little upset because people clearly like it better than us, you know, as flattered about bullshit.
嗯，我真的很高兴，因为我们听说很多人错过乔丹娜的片段，她应该感到非常受宠若惊，我们也许应该有点沮丧，因为人们显然比我们更喜欢它，你知道，因为对废话感到受宠若惊。
But I also like to remind people, I'm still getting questions and observations from a clinical psychologist, who never seen him or me or my mother, who also happened to me.
但我也想提醒人们，我仍然收到临床心理学家的问题和观察，他们从未见过他、我或我的母亲，他们也发生在我身上。
It's a segment for one.
这是一个人的片段。
It's an audience.
这是一个观众。
It's an segment for one.
这是一个人的片段。
I'm sitting next to her on the couch.
我坐在她旁边的沙发上。
She makes great observations.
她做出了很好的观察。
And then I go do the podcast, and some of which they filter into my thinking, but I'm really, she's accepting these ideas into my head.
然后我去做播客，其中一些内容会渗透到我的想法中，但我真的，她正在将这些想法接受到我的脑海中。
What if we discovered she was, at this moment, doing a competing IG live with way more people?
如果我们发现她此时正在与更多的人一起进行竞争性 IG 直播怎么办？
You heard her upstairs, you're like, what, you go up there?
你听到她在楼上的声音，你就想，什么，你上楼去吗？
What are you doing?
你在干什么？
Oh, this is awkward.
哦，这很尴尬。
I'm talking to 5 million people on it right now.
我现在正在和 500 万人谈论这个问题。
How many did you guys have?
你们有多少个？
I heard she's laughing.
我听说她在笑。
Hell, start work 2019 just says, it's a rare show that can make you laugh one moment and cry your eyes at the next, you really set the standard for a television show.
哎呀，《开工2019》就这么说了，难得一会让人笑一会哭的剧，真是树立了电视剧的标准。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you.
That's nice.
那很好。
And Kenneth, playing Josh, I'm sure you get this question.
肯尼斯（Kenneth）扮演乔什（Josh），我相信你会明白这个问题。
A lot of Kenneth, playing says, hey Josh, can you give me some advice?
很多肯尼思在打球时都会说，嘿乔什，你能给我一些建议吗？
Is someone who wants to be an actor or share a story of how you became such a great actor?
有人想成为一名演员或分享你如何成为一名如此出色的演员的故事吗？
Well, I trained a really long time.
嗯，我训练了很长时间。
I did a lot of plays.
我演过很多戏。
I went to a lot of theaters and apprenticed and interned and did non-equity companies, and then I went to grad school and worked around the clock for three straight years.
我去了很多剧院，当过学徒，实习过，还做过非股权公司，然后我读了研究生，连续三年昼夜不停地工作。
And then I got out of school.
然后我就离开了学校。
I was very fortunate to get signed by a really great agent.
我很幸运能得到一位非常出色的经纪人的签约。
And I just started working.
而我刚刚开始工作。
The thing is though, like when I got out of schools, 1999, it was a different world of entertainment.
但问题是，就像 1999 年我离开学校时一样，那是一个不同的娱乐世界。
It was a different, I mean, everything was different.
这是不同的，我的意思是，一切都不同了。
So I think the, you know, there's people who are all, you know, a lot of people are like, the good old days were, blah, blah, blah.
所以我认为，你知道，很多人都喜欢，过去的美好时光是，等等，等等。
And I'm not really one for that kind of nostalgia, but I do think that right now, I don't know that you, you know, if school is your thing, if that's where you thrive, it can be great to go to school and study a craft and be with a company of people that you're learning with.
我并不是那种怀旧的人，但我确实认为，现在，我不知道你，你知道，如果学校是你的事，如果那是你成长的地方，那么去学校学习一门手艺并与一群与你一起学习的人在一起会很棒。
But if you don't have the time, or the wherewithal, or the money to do that, take your phone and start making cool stuff.
但如果你没有时间、资金或金钱来做到这一点，那就拿起你的手机开始制作很酷的东西。
Make cool movies, learn how to edit, learn how to be indispensable.
制作很酷的电影，学习如何剪辑，学习如何变得不可或缺。
You're not gonna be as good as you wanna be.
你不会像你想的那样优秀。
Ira Glass has that great quote about how when you're younger, your taste is much better than your abilities, so it's really hard.
艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）有句名言，说当你年轻的时候，你的品味比你的能力要好得多，所以这真的很难。
and you have to work until your art catches up with your taste, which is probably pretty good, even young.
你必须努力工作，直到你的艺术赶上你的品味，这可能相当不错，即使是年轻的。
So you just gotta get a lot of hours under your belt and work with good people and humble yourself and ask questions and be curious and stay not cynical somehow, you know, because the business is really hard and can beat you up and spit you out.
所以你必须花很多时间和优秀的人一起工作，谦虚自己，提出问题，保持好奇心，不要愤世嫉俗，你知道，因为这个行业真的很难，可能会打败你，然后把你吐出来。
But you just gotta stick with good people and ask the right questions and just be in the right place at the right time, and by that, I mean, just keep going.
但你只需要和优秀的人在一起，提出正确的问题，在正确的时间出现在正确的地点，我的意思是，继续前进。
Yeah.
是的。
Craig, Brendan Yuri-Lover says, I want to know more about your writing career, any future books, you just finished this one, any future books, big fan of the book you wrote, and I want to be an author like you.
克雷格，布伦丹·尤里·洛弗说，我想更多地了解你的写作生涯，任何未来的书，你刚刚完成了这本书，任何未来的书，你写的书的忠实粉丝，我想成为像你一样的作家。
Oh, that's so nice to hear, thank you.
哦，很高兴听到这个消息，谢谢。
Yeah, that was my debut novel, just came out a couple months ago, it's called That's Not How It Happened, please check it out, him and fans have been super kind, And there are definitely some little Hymium Easter eggy kind of things in there.
是的，那是我的处女作，几个月前刚刚出版，它的名字叫《事情不是这样发生的》，请看一下，他和粉丝们都非常友善，而且里面肯定有一些 Hymium 复活节彩蛋之类的东西。
And I think tonally it shares a lot of the heart of Hymium and hopefully some of the humor.
我认为从基调上看，它与 Hymium 有很多共同点，希望也有一些幽默感。
Yeah, I want to read another one.
是的，我想再读一本。
I really do.
我真的这么做。
It takes a long time.
这需要很长时间。
Josh, see Josh's aforementioned comment about parenting taking a lot of time.
乔什，请参阅乔什前述关于养育子女花费大量时间的评论。
There's a lot of that happening.
有很多这样的事情发生。
And doing the pod and stuff.
并做吊舱之类的事情。
I am in the gestational phase of thinking of the next book and this one has been so well received and big shout out to him and fans for that.
我正处于思考下一本书的酝酿阶段，这本书受到了热烈的欢迎，并为此向他和粉丝们大声喊叫。
So I really want to do another one.
所以我真的很想做另一件事。
It's a dream.
这是一个梦。
It isn't an amazing when you, this happens when you go on a press tour for like a huge thing you've done.
当你为自己所做的一件大事进行新闻发布会时，这种情况就会发生，这并不奇怪。
Right, what's next?
对了，接下来呢？
What do you have next?
接下来你有什么？
And it always makes your heart a little bit.
而且总是让你的心有些动摇。
You're like, shit, I don't have it right now.
你会说，妈的，我现在没有。
Is this not enough?
这还不够吗？
I wrote a book, like a whole book.
我写了一本书，就像一整本书一样。
I know, an incredible book, by the way.
顺便说一下，我知道这是一本令人难以置信的书。
I really love this book.
我真的很喜欢这本书。
I think I told Craig, even if he was my sworn enemy, I would be forced to admit he had written a great book.
我想我告诉克雷格，即使他是我的死敌，我也不得不承认他写了一本伟大的书。
It's just such- But then you'd beat me to death with the book.
就是这样——但是你却用这本书把我打死了。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
It's just such a great read.
这真是一本很棒的书。
It's so page 20.
原来是20页啊
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
It's so really about something.
这确实是关于某件事的。
It's one of those books that feels both nourishing intellectually and soulfully, but it's also hilarious and just a joy to read.
这是一本在智力和灵魂上都得到滋养的书，但它也很搞笑，读起来很愉快。
Thanks, my friend.
谢谢，我的朋友。
I really think it was a, you really pulled something off there.
我真的认为这是一个，你真的做到了一些事情。
Thank you, buddy.
谢谢你，伙计。
And Josh and Kobe are two of the four voices in the audiobook, so go check that out.
乔什和科比是有声读物中四个声音中的两个，所以去看看吧。
It is a dream, and it's inspired by my own unique journey.
这是一个梦想，它的灵感来自于我自己独特的旅程。
As a parent, it's inspired by my son, Elliot, who may or may be watching this as we speak.
作为一名家长，它的灵感来自我的儿子埃利奥特，在我们说话时他可能正在观看这一切。
Hello, Elliot, if you are.
你好，埃利奥特，如果你是的话。
And I love him very much, and he inspired this book in so many ways.
我非常爱他，他在很多方面启发了这本书。
Yeah, and it did book borrows from some of my hymium life and Hollywood life, it borrows from my own family.
是的，这本书确实借鉴了我的一些欢乐生活和好莱坞生活，它借鉴了我自己的家庭。
And I will say it's always a great thing when you can write what you know and when you can be taking things from your life and processing them into art.
我想说，当你能写下你所知道的东西，当你能从生活中汲取东西并将它们加工成艺术时，这总是一件很棒的事情。
And I think that probably also speaks to Josh's answer about being an actor.
我认为这可能也说明了乔什关于成为一名演员的答案。
It's like, just keep doing it.
就像，继续做下去。
Just keep living your life and doing your thing and finding how your life filters through you into your art.
只要继续过你的生活，做你的事情，并发现你的生活如何渗透到你的艺术中。
And that is very much what happened with the book.
这就是这本书所发生的事情。
And it does take time.
这确实需要时间。
You have to get lucky.
你必须运气好。
You have to get that right idea, but you know that feeling, right?
你必须得到正确的想法，但你知道那种感觉，对吗？
You know that feeling when you're kind of in it.
当你身处其中时，你就会知道那种感觉。
You're like, this is the right story, this is the right thing.
你会想，这是正确的故事，这是正确的事情。
And I am hoping I'm moving into that zone again with some new ideas for the next one.
我希望我能再次进入这个区域，并为下一个区域带来一些新想法。
But yeah, Stitchin, thank you so much for reading my book.
但是，是的，史蒂钦，非常感谢你阅读我的书。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew where you were sitting.
而这个老人，他一定让我爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告，广告结束，回到演出。
A couple of things here, someone has asked, Wait, are you guys done recording season two?
这里有几件事，有人问，等等，你们第二季录制完成了吗？
And yes, we are, we've just finished episode 22.
是的，我们刚刚完成了第 22 集。
We've done something borrowed, something blue.
我们做了一些借来的东西，一些蓝色的东西。
And this week, I think columns was this week's new episode, right?
本周，我认为专栏是本周的新剧集，对吗？
Just in case people are brand new to this and they're like, where are they in season two?
以防万一人们对此完全陌生，他们会想，第二季他们在哪里？
Columns, our episode of the podcast about the episode column, this dropped Monday.
专栏，我们关于剧集专栏的播客节目，周一发布。
That's kind of what we're up to.
这就是我们要做的。
But unlike how I met your mother, which would take what, a four and a half month break, we'll be taking a much smaller break.
但与我遇见你母亲时需要四个半月的休息时间不同，我们的休息时间要小得多。
So we'll be back with season three quite soon.
所以我们很快就会回归第三季。
Yeah, and to be clear, it may not feel like a break at all, right?
是的，要明确的是，这可能根本不像休息，对吧？
Barely, right?
勉强，对吧？
You'll go to howwemajormother.com.
您将访问 howwemajormother.com。
From there, you can access all of your podcast apps, Apple Podcasts and Spotify and Amazon and a few others.
从那里，您可以访问所有播客应用程序、Apple 播客、Spotify 和亚马逊以及其他一些应用程序。
Few other things, just so everyone knows in the questions here, we are not going to say things that you ask us to say.
很少有其他事情，只是为了让每个人都知道这里的问题，我们不会说您要求我们说的事情。
It's lovely that you want us to say certain things, but if you'd like to just save yourself some time on the typing, it's probably- All right, I'll sing love you on Rose.
你希望我们说某些话真是太好了，但如果你只是想节省一些打字时间，那可能是——好吧，我会在《Rose》中唱《爱你》。
Not other than that.
除此之外没有别的。
If you give us some of the words that Robin had to say on the news, maybe we'll save those.
如果你给我们一些罗宾在新闻中不得不说的话，也许我们会保留这些。
Yes, and possibly the I'm of naughty girl or whatever that was, I don't remember, anyway.
是的，可能是“我是顽皮的女孩”之类的，反正我不记得了。
All right, but send us down and we'll save those.
好吧，但是请派我们下来，我们会保存这些。
So people have asked us before, and actually haven't talked about where the idea came from.
所以人们之前问过我们，但实际上并没有谈到这个想法是从哪里来的。
M.
M。
Frata 07 says, Craig, how did you or Carter come up with having everyone's significant other be in the show?
Frata 07 说，克雷格，你或卡特是怎么想到让每个人的另一半都出现在节目中的？
I love the cameos, such a cool idea.
我喜欢客串，这是一个很酷的主意。
Yeah, it always makes me happy.
是的，它总是让我快乐。
We just talked about something brought out something blue and that in those two, one of those two, I guess in the second, again, the second last episode of season, do you see Neil and David Birka, Neil's then partner and now husband?
我们刚刚谈到了一些带出一些蓝色的东西，在那两个人中，其中一个，我想在第二集，再一次，本季的倒数第二集中，你看到尼尔和大卫·比尔卡，尼尔当时的搭档和现在的丈夫吗？
And it's cool, they're like, there they are in a scene together, and David is so funny and they're seeing each other.
这很酷，他们就像，他们一起在一个场景中，大卫很有趣，他们看到了对方。
And they're like, yeah.
他们就像，是的。
They're just me, they go, hey, scooter, what's up?
他们只是我，他们走了，嘿，滑板车，怎么了？
And they're, they're, they were really funny together in that scene and David's super funny.
他们，他们，他们在那个场景中在一起真的很有趣，大卫超级有趣。
The answer to the question is everyone was so funny.
这个问题的答案是每个人都很有趣。
David's hilarious as scooter.
大卫像摩托车一样搞笑。
Alexis Dennasoff, like Carter and I, and my wife Rebecca got Carter and I into Buffy and Angel.
亚历克西斯·丹纳斯索夫（Alexis Dennasoff），就像卡特和我一样，还有我的妻子丽贝卡（Rebecca）让卡特和我进入了《巴菲与天使》。
And Alexis Dennasoff is so great on Angel.
亚历克西斯·丹纳索夫（Alexis Dennasoff）在《天使》中的表现非常出色。
Anyone who has watched Angel, he was Wesley on Angel.
任何看过《天使》的人都会知道他就是《天使》中的韦斯利。
And he was like, absolutely riveting on that show.
他对那个节目非常着迷。
He's British accented on that show.
他在那个节目中带有英国口音。
And he's really funny at first, a really silly, funny character, like the comic relief, and then goes to a whole other place through the series.
一开始他真的很有趣，一个非常愚蠢、有趣的角色，就像喜剧浮雕一样，然后在整个系列中去了一个完全不同的地方。
It becomes almost like a romantic lead you're rooting for.
它几乎就像是你所支持的浪漫主角。
He's great.
他很棒。
And so funny, Sandy Rivers.
真有趣，桑迪·里弗斯。
So that's the thing, he has those comedy chops.
事情就是这样，他有喜剧天赋。
And people sort of forgot at the end of Angel, his character became very serious and dark.
人们有点忘记了在《天使》的结尾，他的性格变得非常严肃和黑暗。
And people kind of forgot in the industry, I think that he began as a very funny character at the beginning of Angel.
在这个行业里，人们有点忘记了，我认为他在《天使》一开始就是一个非常有趣的角色。
So then, and Carter and I remember that, and we're like, Alexis is hilarious, we know it for a fact, because we saw it in the early seasons of Angel.
然后，卡特和我记得这一点，我们就像，亚历克西斯很搞笑，我们知道这是事实，因为我们在《天使》的前几季中看到了这一点。
So that's why we cast him as Sandy Rivers.
这就是为什么我们让他扮演桑迪·里弗斯。
And Taryn Gillum, I mean, he went on to be on SNL after guesting on our show.
我的意思是，塔林·吉勒姆 (Taryn Gillum) 在客串我们的节目后继续参加了《周六夜现场》(SNL)。
He's hilarious, and this was not us doing favors for significant artists.
他很搞笑，这不是我们在为重要的艺术家提供帮助。
We actually were funny, but we love them all.
我们实际上很有趣，但我们都爱他们。
It is amazing though that like, it was just dumb luck that everyone was like partnered with hilarious people.
令人惊奇的是，每个人都和搞笑的人搭档，这只是运气不好。
like you could have looked at as like spousal favors, but they were like absolutely made the show better.
就像你可以看作是配偶的恩惠，但它们绝对让演出变得更好。
Like bookable actor, yeah, they would come in, they would have come in and got those parts.
就像可预订的演员一样，是的，他们会进来，他们会进来并得到这些角色。
And we instead we just got to say to them like, hey, would you do this and be like, yeah, I'm hanging out anyway.
相反，我们只能对他们说，嘿，你会这样做吗？然后说，是的，无论如何我都会出去玩。
My way thanks on the show, I'm sitting here.
我以我的方式感谢节目，我坐在这里。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay, we've got a very special audience member.
好的，我们有一位非常特殊的观众。
I mean, all our audience members are special, our fans are special, But this one, her name is Angela Kinsey.
我的意思是，我们所有的观众都很特别，我们的粉丝都很特别，但是这个，她的名字是安吉拉·金赛。
She comes from at Angela Kinsey.
她来自安吉拉金赛。
Angela, of course, for everyone.
安吉拉，当然，对每个人来说。
It's bringing people.
它带来了人们。
Who knows, doesn't know, is, of course, from the office and hosts, co-host, which Anna Fisher, the amazing office ladies podcast.
谁知道，谁不知道，当然是来自办公室和主持人，联合主持人，安娜·费舍尔，令人惊叹的办公室女士播客。
And we are part of their network.
我们是他们网络的一部分。
And Angela is listening and watching as we speak.
当我们说话时，安吉拉正在倾听和观察。
Hi Angela.
嗨安吉拉。
And she says, Craig, was there a supporting character that you loved writing a laugh line for?
她说，克雷格，你喜欢为哪个配角写笑点吗？
Like in the office, we get excited if we got the comedy button in a scene.
就像在办公室一样，如果场景中出现喜剧按钮，我们会感到兴奋。
So for you, we're like, oh, I can't wait to get, this character's gonna get a line and gonna knock it out of the park.
所以对你来说，我们就像，哦，我迫不及待地想知道，这个角色会得到一条线，并将其击出公园。
Are we saying a main cast or is this larger?
我们是说主要演员还是更大？
It sounds like she's got a supporting character.
看来她还有个配角。
So maybe a waitress, maybe a bartender, you know, something like that.
所以也许是一名女服务员，也许是一名调酒师，你知道，类似的人。
I think Ranjit pops right into my head immediately.
我想 Ranjit 立刻就出现在我的脑海中。
Josh, you know what I mean?
乔什，你知道我的意思吗？
Because you could write just Ranjit, turn around and say, hello!
因为你可以只写 Ranjit，转身说，你好！
And like Marshall Manesh, that actor which is so funny and charismatic.
就像马歇尔·马内什（Marshall Manesh）一样，这位演员非常有趣且有魅力。
And if hello became a joke for him.
如果你好对他来说变成了一个笑话。
Yeah, which is interesting.
是的，这很有趣。
And it got to feeling like the cast, the characters, and the audience were never not delighted when Ranjit would come by.
当兰吉特出现时，演员、角色和观众都会感到很高兴。
Yeah, it was a hold for applause from an audience that was not there at that level.
是的，这赢得了不在场的观众的掌声。
I also think going through the first two seasons, you forget how much steward.
我还认为经历了前两个赛季，你会忘记有多少管家。
Matt Boren.
马特·博伦。
Matt Boren is a round and so funny.
马特·博伦（Matt Boren）很圆，很有趣。
And also Joe Manganello, like.
还有乔·曼加内罗（Joe Manganello）。
Joe Manganello.
乔·曼加内罗。
He like really pops up in such a funny way throughout those first yeah And then those guys are together as two of the guys on the bachelor party in those last couple of episodes of season two And like Matt and Joe could be like their own like road trip movie.
他确实以一种有趣的方式出现在第一季中，是的，然后这些家伙在一起，作为第二季最后几集单身派对上的两个家伙，就像马特和乔一样，就像他们自己的公路旅行电影一样。
I would watch a movie That's just the two of them.
我会看一场只有他们两个人的电影。
Matt is just like he plays this character's doing with this is long suffering He's just like married to this really intense woman.
马特就像他扮演的这个角色一样，他的所作所为是长期受苦的，他就像嫁给了这个非常强烈的女人。
It's clearly very miserable and Joe Meganello looks like Thor and He doesn't have the miserable he doesn't know how to suffer in that way.
这显然是非常悲惨的，乔·梅加内罗看起来像托尔，他没有那种悲惨的感觉，他不知道如何遭受那样的痛苦。
And he was, but of course on the show, he played Brad who did have his heart broken and essentially kind of dated Marshall for a little while on an episode.
他确实是，但当然在节目中，他扮演的布拉德确实心碎了，并且在某一集中与马歇尔约会了一段时间。
And that, he was so funny because he talked on the Abreaves, you know, going through a bit of a depression.
而且，他很有趣，因为他在 Abreaves 上讲话，你知道，经历了一点抑郁症。
And it's the, this ex-Benny is Redonk when they're on their brunch date.
就是这样，当他们在早午餐约会时，这位前本尼就是雷东克。
It's just like when you could find a Sanzer Angeles question when you could find a character that developed an immediate, like, really recognizable way of speaking It was completely unlike everybody else on the show.
这就像当你能找到一个 Sanzer Angeles 问题时，你能找到一个能够立即发展出一种立即、类似、真正可识别的说话方式的角色，这与节目中的其他人完全不同。
That's a joy.
那是一种喜悦。
That's a joy when you get that.
当你得到它时，那是一种快乐。
Joe was definitely like that way as Brad on the show.
乔在节目中扮演布拉德时肯定是这样的。
George Graham wonders which character would be the worst or best and or best podcast host?
乔治·格雷厄姆想知道哪个角色是最差、最好和/或最好的播客主持人？
Wait, this is.
等等，这是。
Well, Josh Ramner, I think.
嗯，我想是乔什·拉姆纳。
Well, I hope that I would be the best of the character, though, but the character.
好吧，我希望我能成为这个角色中最好的，但是这个角色。
I think Ted was a podcaster before Dr. X, Dr. X.
我认为 Ted 在 X 博士之前就是一名播客，X 博士。
He's an absolute trailblazer.
他是绝对的开拓者。
That's the answer.
这就是答案。
What's a trailblazer?
什么是开拓者？
Ted had a real history in radio.
特德在广播领域有着丰富的历史。
Yes, and never owned up to being Dr. X, even though everyone knew this was his college radio show that aired at midnight, and he was like, he had the alias, and he was, I'm telling you the truth.
是的，他从来没有承认自己是 X 博士，尽管每个人都知道这是他在午夜播出的大学广播节目，他就像，他有化名，而且他是，我告诉你真相。
So I can't let him let my name get out there, because of the word.
所以我不能让他因为这个词而让我的名字泄露出去。
He thought he was like a folk hero, right?
他以为自己就像一个民间英雄，对吗？
Yeah, it was a folk hero.
是的，这是一位民间英雄。
I'm just Dr. Rex.
我只是雷克斯博士。
I'm only here for the truth.
我来这里只是为了真相。
I'm not here to aggrandize myself.
我来这里不是为了夸大自己。
And it was really, he had a sort of dark, webby podcast vibe before the internet existed.
确实，在互联网出现之前，他就有一种黑暗、网络般的播客氛围。
Yeah.
是的。
So definitely Ted is Dr. Rex is the podcast.
所以泰德肯定就是雷克斯博士，播客就是雷克斯博士。
And maybe we should consider doing that, Josh.
也许我们应该考虑这样做，乔什。
What do you want to just, we'll do a podcast that's that?
你想做什么，我们就做一个播客吧？
There's kind of like the seeds of like Robin would have gotten a little hooked by QAnon.
有点像罗宾的种子会被 QAnon 迷住。
Like not fully, but a little, She would have gotten a little stacked up in the gears of it for a while.
就像不是完全，但有一点，她会在一段时间内陷入困境。
There could have been an event.
可能有一个事件。
Until people talked her down.
直到人们劝阻她。
I thought you were going to say Robin would be a good podcast host because she's a newscaster, but instead you went to QAnon.
我以为你会说罗宾会成为一名优秀的播客主持人，因为她是一名新闻主播，但你却去了 QAnon。
So I don't know, I don't know what to say.
所以我不知道，我不知道该说什么。
Maybe she'd be like Carrie Lake.
也许她会像凯莉·莱克一样。
Like she'd like run for office in some like hard right campaign.
就像她想参加一些极右翼竞选活动一样。
Spin off, okay.
甩掉就可以了
We're writing this.
我们正在写这个。
Where is she in 2026?
2026年她在哪里？
Brian underscored Nara does also suggest that Sandy Rivers would be the best and worst podcast host.
布莱恩强调，奈拉确实也暗示桑迪·里弗斯将是最好和最差的播客主持人。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
That's a good one.
这是一件好事。
Yes, I think there's definitely some versions of Sandy Rivers hosting podcasts.
是的，我认为肯定有某些版本的桑迪·里弗斯（Sandy Rivers）主持播客。
And also the bros that Marshall worked with, Marshall with his like sweet-hearted environmental law background goes to work at this horrible corporation that Barney works for.
还有与马歇尔共事的兄弟们，马歇尔有着同样可爱的环境法背景，在巴尼工作的这家可怕的公司工作。
Those bros like Billson and Blauman, I think were their names.
我认为像比尔森和布劳曼这样的兄弟就是他们的名字。
Those guys definitely have a problematic podcast of some kind.
这些人肯定有某种有问题的播客。
Billson and Blauman were two of my favorite names you guys came up with.
比尔森和布劳曼是我最喜欢你们想出的两个名字。
I think Carl MacLaren, our assistant namesake of McLaren's bar, he may have come up with both of those names.
我认为卡尔·麦克拉伦（Carl MacLaren），我们的助理麦克拉伦酒吧的同名者，可能是他想出了这两个名字。
Carl was great at inventing weird fake names that sound like middle managers with short sleeve buttoned down shirts and ties.
卡尔很擅长发明奇怪的假名字，听起来像是穿着短袖纽扣衬衫和领带的中层管理人员。
with like short sleeve button down shirts and ties.
搭配短袖系扣衬衫和领带。
Those are an enble omen.
这些都是一个吉兆。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think finally here, Ashley Chon Sec, who I think maybe has asked some questions from us before I think so, says that I'm saying final one, but if there's more good questions, just keep them coming here.
我想最后在这里，阿什利·琼·塞克（Ashley Chon Sec）说，我说的是最后一个问题，我认为他可能在我这么想之前就向我们提出了一些问题，但如果还有更多好的问题，请让他们来这里。
We'll see.
我们拭目以待。
But asks a lovely question, besides family and friends and the necessities, what is one random thing you absolutely could not live without.
但问了一个可爱的问题，除了家人、朋友和必需品之外，你绝对不能没有的一件随机的东西是什么。
Can I hit pause for one second and just say also, the reason that Angela is messaging us is because Angela and Jenna were kind enough to invite us into the OLN world.
我可以暂停一下，然后再说一下，安吉拉给我们发消息的原因是因为安吉拉和珍娜好心邀请我们进入 OLN 世界。
This is for the new, the people finding this for the first time.
这是给新人的，第一次发现这个的人。
We are part of the Office Ladies Network now.
我们现在是办公室女士网络的一部分。
I think we didn't explain that at all when Angela was ready to get some questions.
我想当安吉拉准备回答一些问题时我们根本没有解释这一点。
I said that a little bit.
我说了一点。
Okay, okay.
好吧，好吧。
But we're very lucky to be part of the Office Ladies Network.
但我们很幸运能够成为办公室女士网络的一部分。
You can find us over by the Empire.
你可以在帝国旁边找到我们。
they're building, they do it the best, they were definitely walking in their footsteps, doing a rewatch pod, the office ladies are amazing, so we were very grateful to them, and we're happy to be part of their team.
他们正在建设，他们做得最好，他们绝对在追随他们的脚步，做一个重看吊舱，办公室女士们都很棒，所以我们非常感谢他们，我们很高兴成为他们团队的一员。
Yes.
是的。
All true.
都是真的。
So as I was thinking back, what do you know about it?
当我回想起来时，你对此了解多少？
So, yeah, the office ladies.
所以，是的，办公室女士们。
Angela and Jenna, we can't leave it out as the answer.
安吉拉和珍娜，我们不能把它作为答案。
Besides family, friends, Angela and Jenna, and the other necessities of life, what is one random thing?
除了家人、朋友、安吉拉和珍娜以及其他生活必需品之外，什么是随机的事情？
What is one thing that you absolutely cannot live without?
什么是你绝对不能没有的东西？
How technically are we gonna get here?
从技术上讲我们要如何到达这里？
Josh, do you have anything?
乔什，你有什么东西吗？
This is a tough question.
这是一个很难回答的问题。
Well, I don't think I should answer.
嗯，我想我不应该回答。
Like if I should look for like a soul answer or just like a material fact kind of answer.
就像我是否应该寻找灵魂答案或只是物质事实类型的答案。
What would you take with you other than your child and your house is on fire?
除了你的孩子和你的房子着火了，你还能带走什么？
Yeah, I would take a guitar.
是的，我会带一把吉他。
Like I would take my guild guitar.
就像我会带着我的公会吉他一样。
Yeah.
是的。
I have the same answer.
我也有同样的答案。
I literally, that's exactly what popped into my head when I was outside of it.
确实，当我身处其中时，这正是我脑海中浮现的内容。
I think music, I couldn't live without music.
我认为音乐，没有音乐我就活不下去。
It's, music brought me everything.
是的，音乐给我带来了一切。
Like music, like music is how, doing, playing music with Carter in college is how we became friends and created how much mother.
喜欢音乐，喜欢音乐是怎么做的，在大学里和卡特一起玩音乐是我们如何成为朋友并创造了多少母亲。
So if you take it all the way back, I feel like how much mother came out of music.
所以如果你回顾过去，我觉得母亲是从音乐中走出来的。
And every, so many of the good things in my life came out of music.
我生命中的一切美好事物都来自音乐。
Playing in bands in college, like I met my wife and my son Elliot is like this little musical being.
在大学里在乐队里演奏，就像我遇到了我的妻子和儿子艾略特一样，就像这个小小的音乐人。
my daughter Celia just took up the saxophone.
我的女儿西莉亚刚刚开始吹萨克斯管。
And has this really cool two-tone saxophone like, it's because of Lisa Simpson.
拥有这种非常酷的双音萨克斯风，都是因为丽莎·辛普森。
Cause she loves the Simpson so much, she's like, I'm gonna play that instrument like Lisa.
因为她非常喜欢辛普森一家，她想，我要像丽莎一样演奏这个乐器。
And we were like, we're gonna buy her a saxophone cause she likes Lisa, what if she doesn't stick with it?
我们当时想，我们要给她买一支萨克斯管，因为她喜欢丽莎，如果她不坚持怎么办？
She loves it, she's totally crushing it and sticking with it.
她喜欢它，她完全粉碎它并坚持下去。
It's not easy.
这并不容易。
Yeah, it's a tough, yeah, she takes the last number of week and she's like really good, she's into recital.
是的，这很艰难，是的，她花了最后一周的时间，她真的很好，她参加了独奏会。
And Elliot is playing drums and keyboards I'm like singing in his family players.
埃利奥特（Elliot）演奏鼓和键盘，我就像在他的家庭演奏家中唱歌。
It is, we're trying to become the Vontraps.
是的，我们正在努力成为 Vontraps。
And it's that part of life is, I wouldn't want to live in a world without that.
这就是生活的一部分，我不想生活在一个没有它的世界里。
You know, it's like that has been such a part of my life.
你知道，这就像我生活的一部分。
And yeah, that's what I, that's a necessity.
是的，这就是我，这是必要的。
I have a teddy bear.
我有一只泰迪熊。
That's the teddy bear would always go first.
那是泰迪熊总是先走。
I've gotten ready to take with me.
我已经准备好随身携带了。
Barry.
巴里.
Does this go back to childhood?
这是要回到童年吗？
Is this like the original teddy bear?
这和原来的泰迪熊一样吗？
No, or you still have this right now.
不，或者你现在还拥有这个。
I still have it right now.
我现在还留着它。
Absolutely go get it on Instagram live.
绝对要去 Instagram 上直播。
That's too far away.
那太遥远了。
It's too far Way next time next time Just a quick shout out to Marco 1503 who said I got to be an extra on the show.
太远了下次下次只是向 Marco 1503 大声喊叫，他说我必须在节目中当临时演员。
It was great cool Yeah, all right, so Let's see.
太酷了是的，好吧，让我们看看。
Yeah, I think I think that's probably gonna be our our Instagram live for today We'll just say a few quick things one is that yes, yes, please please there is a podcast Please tell four or five of your hymium-loving friends.
是的，我想这可能就是我们今天的 Instagram 直播，我们只想简单地说几句话，其中之一是，是的，是的，拜托拜托，有一个播客，请告诉四五个喜欢 hymium 的朋友。
There's also a great Facebook group.
还有一个很棒的 Facebook 群组。
It's called Major Fans.
这就是所谓的大粉丝。
Major Fans.
主要粉丝。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Go over to them.
到他们那里去。
It's like a private group, so you'll go in.
这就像一个私人团体，所以你会进去。
It's a lovely community of people talking about all this.
这是一个可爱的社区，人们谈论这一切。
I post things a lot there.
我在那里发布了很多东西。
I answer people's questions.
我回答人们的问题。
I ask four people's questions to ask of Josh and Craig.
我向乔什和克雷格提出了四个人的问题。
Check that out.
检查一下。
These These Instagram lives, the audio will appear, eventually, in the podcast, Bead.
这些 Instagram 生活的音频最终将出现在播客 Bead 中。
And again, just for you here, we're not really going to tell you too much.
再说一遍，对于这里的您，我们不会告诉您太多。
We're just going to say that we did just record something very special.
我们只是想说，我们确实录制了一些非常特别的东西。
And you're all going to get to not just- Did I do that?
你们所有人都会不只是——我这样做了吗？
We'll explain it later.
我们稍后会解释。
Sorry.
对不起。
That was right.
没错。
And you are all going to get to not just hear it, but see it on YouTube in a couple of weeks.
几周后，你们不仅会听到，还会在 YouTube 上看到它。
Yeah.
是的。
one more thing like if you love how I met your mother and you love it in a I don't know like if it's just a comfort show or you like to have it on the background that's cool but there's a whole kind of thing we're doing like it almost feels like Craig and I are both students and professors in a college course dedicated to how I met your mother like we are really peeling back the layers of the themes of I think if you're interested in telling stories and hearing from like like a master storyteller, like Craig, who has such deep insights into what they were doing and how they were thinking about it and what they had planned and what was an accident and all kinds of stuff.
还有一件事，比如如果你喜欢我如何遇见你母亲，你喜欢它在一个我不知道这只是一个慰藉节目还是你喜欢把它放在背景上，这很酷，但我们正在做一整套事情，感觉就像克雷格和我都是大学课程的学生和教授，致力于我如何遇见你母亲，就像我们真的在剥开主题的层次，我想如果你有兴趣像大师一样讲故事和听故事像克雷格这样的讲故事的人，对他们在做什么、如何思考、计划什么、什么是意外以及各种各样的事情有着如此深刻的洞察力。
So if you want to know just how this thing got made and what was asked of us as actors and how we collaborated with the writers and the director and everyone, it's a really like 360 view of a show that a lot of people love and that we happen to be world's leading experts on.
所以，如果你想知道这部作品是如何制作的，对我们作为演员有什么要求，以及我们如何与编剧、导演和每个人合作，这是一个非常像 360 度视角的节目，很多人都喜欢，而我们恰好是世界领先的专家。
We were there, we know what happened, we know what didn't happen, we know what it took to make it.
我们在那里，我们知道发生了什么，我们知道没有发生什么，我们知道需要付出什么才能做到这一点。
We have different insight now that we're older and we're a couple years down the line from it.
现在我们年纪大了，而且距离这个目标还有几年的时间，我们有了不同的见解。
But to me, I'm just learning so much about this show we made.
但对我来说，我只是对我们制作的这个节目了解了很多。
Like I'm learning things every week, like from Craig.
就像我每周都在学习东西，就像从克雷格那里学习一样。
If you love the show and you want to go deeper and you know my mother-in-law listens and she's never even seen an episode of how I do mother I don't think she's planning on watching it she just likes listening to it so even if you don't have any interest in the show it's still apparently a great show to listen to so that's just a little just a deeper apply for the podcast How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
如果你喜欢这个节目，你想更深入地了解，你知道我的岳母在听，她甚至从未看过《我如何做母亲》的一集，我认为她不打算看它，她只是喜欢听它，所以即使你对这个节目没有任何兴趣，它显然仍然是一个很棒的节目，所以这只是对播客的一个更深入的应用，我们如何让你的母亲由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持和执行制作，是由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和分发。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point2Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point2Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在克雷格·托马斯的处女作之后，无论在哪里出售书籍，情况都不是这样的，请在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。